you are so original you're such an
original filmmaker and you've influenced
so many people and you've been very
public about the fact that you are
against the way film is taught in school
yes too many things who cannot teach in
school and it's way too long
young people waste 3 4 years of their
lives in the basics of filmmaking you
can learn in a week so you are against
kids going to film school spending a lot
of time and sitting and listening to
lectures that they should be out there
and it should be more visceral it should
be more human it should be sure okay
well what about you started your own
film school okay called the so how dare
you
I don't like film school but you started
one called the rogue film school what
are your students learn specifically
which is in contrast to everything that
you normally see I them for example how
to pick locks and how to forge a
document a shooting permit move the ship
over a mountain yeah and I ran into a
border war between Peru and Ecuador I
was right at the border and I was all of
us have not allowed to move my ship or
to anything so I said to the colonel who
ran this military camp I said to him but
I have a shooting permit and he said
show it to me and I said well it's in
Italy might I bring it to you in three
days and I brought a beautiful
beautifully crafted permit which would
allow me literally everything and I
showed it to him and I said my Coronel
Colonel just read this now and he looked
at it and he starts to read and he
saluted and said move on
what you're teaching that yeah this this
sacred right of trespassing sometimes
you have to take it you have to you have
to break you have to break rules you
have to break rules sinful ask you
sometimes yes to get a great film made
yes
you